ein us forschungsteam ist der
künstlichen photosynthese im
industriellen maßstab jetzt ein
stückchen näher gekommen
damit könnte aus wasser und licht
treibstoff gewonnen werden auf einen
schlag werden quasi alle energieprobleme
der welt gelöst
bisher schienen die künstliche
photosynthese im größerem maßstab
allerdings unnötig mit welcher methode
wie dieses ziel jetzt trotzdem mehr
gekommen sind und welche folge wie
bereits in einem ersten praxistest haben
jetzt in klicks um science-fiction
herzlich willkommen wir alle lernen in
der schule wie photosynthese
funktioniert pflanzen verwenden die
energie der sonne um aus wasser also
wassermolekülen wasserstoff und
sauerstoff abzuspalten diese nutzen sie
für sich und produzieren daraus sehr
energiereiche organische verbindung
pflanzen gelingt dies bereits seit
jahrmillionen auch wenn menschen machen
und diesen mechanismus zu nutzen
bei der sogenannten photokatalytische
wasserspaltung produzieren wir mit hilfe
von licht und wasser beispielsweise
wasserstoff oder andere
umweltfreundliche treibstoffe
doch es gibt ein großes problem dabei
an dem forscherteam weltweit seit
einiger zeit dürfte diese künstliche
photosynthese funktioniert nur mit einem
katalysator ein katalysator ist ein
zusätzliches chemisches element das die
chemische reaktion überhaupt in gang
web oder beschleunigt aber am schluss
der reaktion unverändert weit doch
bislang ist dazu noch kein effektives
material das sich als optimaler
katalysator eignen würde
identifiziert worden bislang werden
meist edelmetalle wie iridium
beispielsweise genutzt doch sie sind
teuer selten und gleichzeitig auch noch
ineffizient wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftler weltweit konnten den
letzten 40 jahren nur 16 materialien
finden die gegebenenfalls als
katalysator 1000 können dabei wäre es
wirklich großartig wenn wir die
künstliche photosynthese effizient noch
zu retten
denn wirklich ist eine unerschöpfliche
und saubere energiequelle und auch die
aus ihren gewonnenen treibstoffe wie
beispielsweise wasserstoff wind
umweltfreundlich und könnten
herkömmliche antriebsarten ablösen
manche experten wählen wasserstoff als
energiespeicher der zukunft denn bei
seiner verbrennung im auto wird relativ
viel energie frei
und es entstehen keine schadstoffe
natürlich gibt es auch hier noch
hürden zu meistern werden was heißt
dass beispielsweise hochexplosiv und
seine speicherung und betankung die ist
hoch problematisch wenn man sich
nämlich dass chemischen periodensystem
anbietet ist er an der ersten stelle und
wasserstoff ist natürlich auch kein
molekül sondern ein atom und das am
anfang des periodensystems steht ist es
auch das kleinste atom mit nur einem
proton und einem elektron es ist damit
so klein dass es überall durchkommt
selbst aus einer gasflasche entweicht s
line war ja auch wenn es oft als a2
vorkommt dennoch die fahndung nach
aussichtsreichen kandidaten läuft auf
hochtouren und nur meldet sich ein us
forscherteam mit einem ersten erfolg die
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
haben einen prozess entwickelt der auf
grundlage von automatisierten
experimenten in der lage ist geeignete
verbindung schneller und effektiver
aufzuspielen gleich zwölf
vielversprechende verbindung haben wir
in einem praxistest identifiziert und
zwar mit hilfe von computern ließ sich
im molekül datenbanken auf die suche
machen und automatisiert experimente
durchführen die forscherinnen und
forscher nutzen dafür ein reaktor der
potenzielle katalysator kandidaten nach
rezept produzieren kann
im übertragenen sinne also ein molekül
kocher eine art school gerät erzeugt
dabei neue moleküle als film schuss auf
den platten diese so zubereiteten
moleküle werden durch hitze
weiterverarbeitet bevor sie dann
sonnenlicht ausgesetzt werden mit einem
foto spektrometer wird ihre fähigkeit
gemessen nicht zu absorbieren
dies gibt einen ersten hinweis auf
vielversprechende kandidaten die werden
ausgewählt und in einem zweiten gerät
getestet ob und wie gut sie lichtenergie
in elektrochemische reaktion umsetzen
das spannende daran diese test passieren
tatsächlich 100 bis 1000 fach schneller
als althergebrachte methoden und das
auch noch erfolgreich das
us-forscherteam lief in einen ersten
test 174 verbindungen von sauerstoff und
vanadium in einem metall überprüfen
und tatsächlich zwölf aussichtsreiche
elektroden kandidaten konnten
identifiziert werden
das ist echt der wahnsinn zwölf stück
wobei in den letzten vier jahrzehnten
insgesamt nur 16 identifiziert
das ergebnis macht tatsächlich hoffnung
dass die suche nach geeigneten
katalysatoren für die künstliche
photosynthese ab jetzt viel schneller
vonstatten gehen wird und vielleicht ist
schon ein katalysator dabei der
preiswert und effektiv funktioniert
strom aus wasser und sonnenlicht das
wäre echt die lösung zahlreiche
umwelt- und tatsächlich aller
energieprobleme
denn mit wasserstoff können
brennstoffzellen betrieben werden kein
erdöl mehr kein strom aus atom- oder
kohlekraftwerken es wäre wie
regenerative energie ich bin sehr
gespannt und halten euch natürlich auf
dem laufenden wenn er kein video zum
thema und auch zu allen anderen themen
verpassen wollt dann wird mir hier ein
abo aufs auge und vergesst nicht den
genau auf die glocke hier geht es weiter
also hier wird die lüge der
energiewende sehr spannendes video
natürlich also nicht verpassen
draufklicken und viel spaß dabei
ansonsten bis dann bleib dran